[Music]
[Applause]
I think Jeremy Lin started his career
with the Golden State Warriors I don't
think he was drafted but uh he's he had
a few stops along the way and he was a
good player and a good ivy league player
but I don't think that he made any news
nationally if you watched Harvard then
you might have thought oh that guy
pretty good he can shoot he can score I
think one season he averaged 18 a game
but kind of a nondescript
pro basketball player
so then he goes to the New York Knicks
and then all of a sudden you know the
Knicks had some injuries and then Jeremy
Lin all of a sudden gives us Lynn sanity
and uh once again the documentary will
be October 11th on HBO and HBO Max 38 in
the garden Jeremy Lin joins us now where
are you right now Jeremy
I'm in Guangzhou in China what's the
town like
um so it's like a it's a city in
southern uh in southern China very nice
weather
um
there's it's like it's a very
food-centric place
um there's a lot of amazing dim sum out
here and it's just like uh yeah in
general it's a very I'm trying to think
of an analogy
um but it's just like a hot hot
temperature
um very very energetic and enthusiastic
people
um and that's kind of the vibe of the
city
how crazy did it get the coverage of
Lynn sanity
uh
it's about as
I mean for sure definitely the craziest
thing I've ever experienced
um you know talking to my teammates the
craziest thing by far they had ever seen
um I mean
yeah I don't think there's too many
people on the planet who have
experienced crazier things
um it was pretty wild it was pretty wild
but did you feel like you were a pop
star like it was more than basketball
oh I mean it was that was literally the
most popular person on the planet like
literally
um like I was the most Google search I
was the most like I was
actually the most searched most talked
about most popular person of that year
and it was a lot it was really
overwhelming
um it was definitely pop star feelings
for sure um it was like what is
happening what just happened because
yesterday I could walk down the street
and today I have Paparazzi uh chasing me
down chasing my family down chasing my
grandma down in in you know in Asia
chasing down my high school teammates
and and my old coaches and everything
across the entire you know across the
world just wherever they were people
were at Paparazzi and reporters were
chasing them down it was like what
happened
did you lose yourself in that
it's close
um I definitely lost myself in many ways
I don't think all all the way
um
but
I lost a lot
um I lost my trust in people
I lost my Foundation of who I am as a
person uh getting caught up in trying to
be who everyone else wanted me to be
um I lost my sense of Joy I lost my
sense of purpose I I lost the innocence
and the naiveness that I came into the
NBA with
um and and I just kind of was covered
with a with a cloud of jadedness and
bitterness and anger
um
so I definitely lost myself many times
along the way I just think I had the
right people around me and um and time
to be able to heal
why the game against the Lakers the the
title 38 at the Garden
because I think that's the most
Monumental game
um and I think
that was definitely like the Pinnacle of
it I mean I know we have the game winner
in Toronto and and that's and that is an
amazing shot that is amazing game as
well but when you think about the height
of it all the build up the the game
being played at MSG the the the hype
around Kobe and what the what had
happened before and interview all of
that I mean it was the Lakers versus the
Knicks in New York I mean that was the
Pinnacle
what did Kobe say to you during the game
or after the game any uh conversation
nothing nothing not until we became
teammates and then uh he gave me a lot
of nice words and a lot of respect but
that was three years down the road it
takes him a while to give you a
compliment but you got one eventually no
I got it eventually though it's playing
hard to get if you had a do-over look
what would you do anything different
I would do a lot of things different
I'll do a lot of things different
um I would enjoy it way more I would
slow down way more
I would embrace the moment I wouldn't
just move on to the next game or the
next goal or the next season
um I wouldn't you know uh I would have
made a lot of different decisions off
the court
um who to trust what path to take and
most importantly I would have
I would have understood
more of how to use that moment and that
platform and my voice to use it more
powerfully at that moment all I could
think about was survival trying to not
get cut
trying to take care of my family and
repay my my loans and get out of debt
and lots of things that you know as a 23
year old I was trying to figure out
right like you know I didn't get a
scholarship I had
I had hundreds of thousands of dollars
that I owed for my tuition I had two
parents who were out of the job I had
two brothers who were in school and not
making any income like
you know it was
I was dealing with a lot and that's
where my mind was at and I was just
trying not to get cut I was just trying
to make it and I was just trying to
establish myself and have a career I
didn't understand what was happening
within the context of society at large
and within the context of of of what
that moment meant culturally
why were you only able to capture Lynn
sanity for that moment that it didn't
spread out he had a good career he
played for a lot of teams but at 34
you're playing in China why
I think there's a lot of reasons
um but ultimately
um
you know there's
I just think that's that's what ended up
happening I got hurt you know I
have dealt with a lot of injuries lots
of surgeries I had a great opportunity
in Brooklyn
um and and got and missed 130 games over
the course of two seasons and had you
know a knee injury that made it so that
my body will never ever be the same
um and
and things happen you know there are
times when I didn't play well enough or
opportunities that I didn't fully take
advantage of and ways that I needed to
get better and wasn't prepared for and
there's a lot of things outside of my
control as well but at the end of the
day I don't feel
um
I feel very honored and privileged to
still be playing and be playing here
with the fan base that I have as well I
mean it's playing out here is you know
that's the only other thing that
compares to kind of what I felt during
the insanity I mean it's amazing that
the basketball fever and the support
that is that is happening out here and
so
um I'm still I'm still really grateful
and blessed to be able to still be doing
this 13 years in
how did your popularity affect your
teammates in particular Carmelo I saw
where he wasn't part of the documentary
what kind of impact do you think that
had on him since it was his team
um I you know and I think this is
something that will always be
speculation
um I never knew then I don't know now
I've never had a conversation about it
personally with him
um but the only thing I and I've said
this and is I don't say it just to like
be fake is I've never had a conflict
with them personally
um everything that happened everything
that you know
is what I know you know what I mean like
everything I heard from you know when
when the Antoni came out multiple years
later when Amari came out multiple years
later like in the moment I didn't know
any of that stuff I didn't know it was
happening I thought the Nick the Knicks
were gonna match me
um they told me they were gonna match me
I just assumed it like I didn't
understand what was happening and uh and
I still don't know
to this day exactly what happened but I
do know that was a magical moment that
was an amazing season and he's part of
the story and he was part of our team
and and uh and we don't make the
playoffs without him
um so you know there's you know from my
end it's looking back you know I don't
dwell on that that aspect of it no
interest in sitting down and talking to
him
oh definitely you know there's
definitely that interest in
um
and uh but we I don't I just don't think
it's it has worked out
um yet but you know on my end definitely
definitely there's that interest
you're lighting up Derek Fisher I'm
looking at the highlights here poor
Derek Fisher that night at the Garden
he had him on skates there
um
yeah I mean I don't think Derek Fisher's
sweating that game anymore you know uh
have you accomplished what he's
accomplished so I think I think she's
like yeah go ahead and have that one
I'll take all my rings
hey
um it's a great documentary and I hope
people uh get a chance to watch it for a
lot of different reasons there and uh a
lot to be proud of
um glad you're still playing hoops and
thanks for joining us
I appreciate it thank you it's Jeremy
Lynn
the HBO documentary 38 at the Garden
debuts October 11th on HBO and HBO Max